all right so here's the thing about dead
people right they're dead
[Music]
today's episode of answer to the
internet is brought to you by curves
stick around after the episode for more
details what's up I'm Daniel priori and
I'm back to answer the internet would
you rather have a 10 inch dick that's
easy but I'll read it would you rather
have a 10 inch dick with no balls or a
four inch dick with balls so now this
shout out to my I've had a couple
friends who've had testicular cancer
right
I'm gonna take the dick I'm going 10
inch dick because balls especially in
porn they're gross and then every once
in a while you see them having sex and
like one ball kind of disappears yeah
have you ever seen that yes
where's the testicle go because you can
have balls that are gross if you have
pretty balls that's different you know
I've never really had anybody say just
like yo I love you I love your I love
your [ __ ] super guys like the only
thing that I've ever would miss is the
constant how much I grab my balls the
constant dudes love grabbing well no no
if I could just like you know sit how I
want to sit and walk out that's what I'm
saying no that's the truth
if I could get more aerodynamic by
having no testicles would be kind of
cool and this this is a mess this is a
mess just give me that 10 inch [ __ ] with
no balls it's like one and now I can't
get to secular cancer right that's the
other thing is no balls no no balls a
good chance yeah give me that 10 inch
dick all day whoa
uh would you rather prematurely come in
your pants before sex or start crying
mid-sex that's a good question I've done
both in in the pants for more sex
uh yeah I've came to my parents yeah for
sure I'd rather start crying mid-sex
though to be honest because I know that
I could talk my way out of that you
could be like this is the most this is
the most beautiful moment of my entire
life that I just had to cry like your
vagina's that Lit if you had a hot
stalker
who was crazily obsessed with you would
you [ __ ] her I mean yeah guys yeah I
mean but this is who hasn't who hasn't
done this already though
who hasn't had a situation like this I
wish I was a little too into you
someone's a little too into you and you
know you're not that into them so like
you're you you're being cordial because
like you don't want them to like go off
the deep end yeah but like some
sometimes you just have to [ __ ] you know
this is how you end up on Netflix but
yeah if she's hot dude would you rather
shoot webs like Spider-Man or have claws
like Wolverine both come out of your
dick shooting a web out of your penis
is so cool so you're already kind of do
it like we talked about that earlier
like I guess it was never having a small
load again which Spider-Man web are we
talking about Toby Maguire built in the
body or that [ __ ] canister [ __ ]
organic built from the body it's
basically like sticky cup yeah dude yeah
because you started only fans with that
and you're [ __ ] good for life would
you rather have a dog die every time you
laugh oh man
go on or have there be a genocide every
time you fall in love
so hopefully I'm done falling in love
um this is a really tough one I love
dogs but I have to go with the food
chain and say that human lives are
probably more important than dog lives I
fall in love hard too like really fast
um
aren't reported no yeah yeah history
that's what I'm saying like yeah like
when they look at me like like
hitler-esque like after this just
because I fell in love he knew all he
had to do was not fall in love that's
true he did it anyway yeah you know what
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm gonna laugh more than I Fall In Love
so
I just I'm gonna hope for the genocide
and hope that it's just all bad people
yeah you swayed me let me keep the dogs
All Dogs Go to Heaven by the way though
too so that's the other argument the
Pope says so yeah so I would be sending
dogs to heaven but yeah I'll ride with
the dogs would you rather have no music
for the rest of your life or have all
music be sung by your significant other
[ __ ] no love my fiance to death
can't sing a [ __ ] lick
um
but you want to know something I will I
would let her sing to me because music's
such a big part of my life that if I
could not have to listen to music for
the rest of my life
I don't think I I don't think I would be
capable of living like a happy life yeah
I'll let my significant other be able to
sing to me because music's just such a
big part of my life and it's kind of
what I do for a living so I would need
it that's a big one that's a big one
would you have sex with a dead person
God damn it dude would you have sex with
a dead person for five minutes
if you'd get your laundry done and
folded magically for the rest of your
life holy [ __ ] [ __ ] all right so
here's the thing about dead people right
they're dead
they're dead right they're dead yeah
like is it a crime that I'm assuming the
laundry's free right yeah oh yeah the
laundry's free
I'm so lazy that I would have to give
this dead person the best five minutes
of their life their afterlife
I'll give you the best five minutes of
their afterlife get my laundry done and
folded for sure
would you take four million dollars to
be caught on To Catch a Predator no now
I now I love money I love money right I
love me some money but though I think
the one thing that I love more than
money is child safety so four million
not enough for me to get that's you know
you got to remember that that's just
forever dude forever and also you're
you're [ __ ] disgusting no but here's
the deal but no no children were harmed
in making this bet you are not a
predator you were Chris Hansen the first
time I ever [ __ ] up so you are proven
you have proven innocent in the court of
law or whatever later like do they leak
my chat and [ __ ] what's my screen name
boner boner guy
big big brown balls 14. daddy Danny Low
yeah if if they have to leak my
transcripts I can't do it nah dude
because then I know like I just think of
it in this the serious sense like I have
to go and like face my family after that
like imagine going facing your family
after you just you can't what do you
tell them uh I got caught trying to [ __ ]
a kid it wasn't real sorry this this
question should be would you take four
million dollars to kill yourself that's
that's what this question should be
yeah would you take four million dollars
to kill yourself because everyone knows
that you're a disgusting piece of [ __ ]
if it was 40 million maybe I'll do
something maybe maybe you know if you up
to Anthony I'll I'll check these kids
out uh would you rather wake up to a
[ __ ] or a hundred dollars under your
pillow every morning give me a hundred
dollars 100 pounds 100 bones give me a
hundred bucks
yeah
I want a hundred dollars under my pillow
every morning because first of all
I can go get a [ __ ] with a hundred
dollars yeah it's not gonna be a great
one it might be Hunt's Point Shadow
Hunt's Point but like you know who
wouldn't want money you'll find a
[ __ ] somewhere you can you'll fall
ass backwards I think it's I think it's
easier to find a [ __ ] than it is to
find a hundred dollar bill you got to
get yourself a curve card you can put
all your debit cards and credit cards
all in one easy to use spot also it's
got that good weight to it so it looks
cool with one of your black cards plus
you get free curved cash and additional
points on top of the regular points you
earn for all your other cards go to
curve.com 20 in curve cash terms apply
Mary [ __ ] kill Legends of the Hidden
Temple guts
double dare damn dude I'm gonna marry
guts because the reason I'm gonna marry
guts is because I know I could get off
that aggro crack especially in my Peak
the Agro aggro Craig stood no chance and
I want a piece of that [ __ ] I tried to
buy one on eBay imagine like getting
drunk though somewhere just remember
guts I won a piece of the Agro that's
the biggest Flex so I'm gonna marry guts
also because the way that Mike O'Malley
used to throw a tamale he's like he's
like yell at her and then Mo was like
Jeremy's in first place with a hundred
points well Mike I would have thrashed
her too
um I'm gonna [ __ ] Legends of the Hidden
Temple uh because
there was something that was scary about
when those like grown men would come out
and just grab those [ __ ] also impossible
it was like run through this in 12
seconds and collect 95 medallions while
grown men attacked you yeah and then you
have to say a sentence with a mouth
guard in your mouth and like turn the
head a certain way to like put it on
Legends of the Hidden Temple I'll [ __ ]
that because I want those big strong
guys to [ __ ] grab me and trap me in
the little [ __ ] Temple but um and
then double dare I didn't like because
you had to reach up that [ __ ]
disgusting nose yeah that stuff for guys
with anxiety yeah I can't go I can't be
digging of some [ __ ] guy's nose I
have health anxiety and [ __ ] I couldn't
do it I'll kill that [ __ ]
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out